you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum we're gonna get to our
wonderful guest Laura Vandervoort in
just a second you know super girl from
Smallville V Wars my ex-girlfriend from
years ago and all that first of all
we're taking a little break like we do
every year well last year was really the
first year but we're gonna take Ryan
we're gonna take Christmas break yeah
we're gonna take the 24th off which is
Christmas Eve you guys don't to be
listening on Christmas Eve anyway and
then the 31st New Year's Eve so those
two two weeks we're gonna take off but
we're gonna come back and also I want to
give Ryan here a little break Bryce my
producer has been working his ass off as
well and Mia my editor I want them to
give a chances for them to see their
family just chill out you see anybody
else really anybody but me stay away
from me
so no podcast for the 24th and 31st so
you guys are aware we will be back on
January 7th ready to go baby Ryan we're
gonna be ready to go by the way did you
get still it's an old episodes if you're
bored or if you're like I want to catch
up you haven't listened to one we're
gonna come in at 2020 with a few sweet
episodes Stephen Amell I'm just gonna
announce it I'm just gonna say it from
arrow
I mean arrow is exploding all over but
you're gonna hear much more about his
life and if you're not an arrow fan
you're still gonna love it also to
actress from Lord of the Rings or coming
on the show in the beginning of the year
very excited and also my producer Bryce
and I are working on something in the
beginning year for a really tasty treat
for everybody so for the new year you'll
want to stick around to see this so come
January I believe it's the 7th we're
gonna go balls out here trust me
also and for the holiday look if you you
know those cameo things I do the Cameo
things so if you want a personalized
video for me you can tell me what to say
I'm a puppet I also want to thank all of
you for your messages about my
grandfather
Irving's passing it's been really tough
and I'm staying busy but reading your
messages it makes me smile my
grandmother was like oh my god there's a
thousand messages I go look at these
things they're saying and she was just
taken aback I don't think anybody read
it would be taken aback but she was so
happy and you made her smile and I
really appreciate that and your loyalty
to the show to me
to my family and friends thank you
everyone who came to the Roxy a few
weeks ago to watch us perform left on
Laurel and those stage that we did a
stage it's so if I ever tell you about a
stage it we do online performances so
it's like an online you know you can go
and watch us recording or playing music
and in my basement pretty much and we
had a whole bunch of great people and
prizes given away I'll let you know when
we do it again but Leah Stubbs Brandi
Edie chose Sergent bitty Betty sick you
guys rock top bidders Happy Holidays
it's been a good year Ryan hasn't it
well it's been great what are you gonna
do for the new year for the new year
oh you know I'm gonna hang out with you
bunch okay that's good you know I
haven't figured it out I appreciate your
honesty well you know look this has been
a challenging year for me and a great
year when I say challenging you guys
know I went I went away for a while to
get my head together lost my grandfather
was my best friend had some [ __ ] going
on but I was in a dark place and I and I
got through it or you know I - I got
through it you guys helped me through it
but I'm still going through it we all
are going through it we consistently
every day is a new day and I'm here
you're here and I really have fallen in
love with this podcast it's giving me
purpose there was a woman who came up to
me at the last con in England crying and
saying how much inside of you affected
her life you never think you're gonna
change people's lives when you do
anything you do it because oh this is
fun and then you start to realize it
might just make an impact on people's
lives so that's cool so thank you for
that I'm very grateful for you I've
learned a tremendous amount this year
I've learned from my guests I have
learned from Ryan I have learned mostly
from you guys when you tweet me or
message me or email Jess about the
podcast I read them all don't think I
don't there's a lot so if I don't
respond all the time in fact after this
episode today you're about to listen to
Laura Vandervoort
we're gonna do a new thing intros outros
I'm gonna tell you some things that's
going that are going on in the beginning
I'm gonna tell you what I think about
the episode after and read some messages
from you guys so you might want to stick
around for that
lastly and maybe many of you are doing
it and I've
talk to you about it a lot but it's the
holidays and if you aren't following
inside of you please just take a few
seconds on social to follow us at inside
of you podcast on Twitter Instagram
Facebook you can catch up on merch
episode highlights bonus content we have
for the week you know like those sweet
videos I shoot while I'm interviewing
folks look it's so important for you
guys to subscribe and get your pals and
family to that way I could pay Ryan and
Bryce and our kick-ass producer and
Cassandra my publicist all these people
you know we do it for free or they don't
do it for free but you listen to it for
free so now you know why I'm asking you
to get more subscribers and all that
stuff but thanks for your loyalty and
I'm just very proud of the the guys and
gals at work on here on the on the
podcast Thank You Jessica
I don't know what I'd do without you and
also you know we have a sweet merch
store go to inside of you podcast comm
tons of cool [ __ ] left on Laurel [ __ ]
band stuff all that that's about it
we're gonna get into Laura Vandervoort
remember we're gone for the next two
weeks but you could listen to old
episodes we're back on the seventh with
a big episode a couple of doozies and
that's it I'm gonna have to talk to you
after the show
let's get inside Laura Vandervoort it's
my
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
yeah I wanted to say congrats on your
album drop thank you
that's quite kind of you did you
download it no well you're going to
write I mean with you sitting here I
probably will have to work it I think
you know I'm sure I'll love it I've
heard one of the songs that you had was
your hometown radio played oh it was
great
I think what was that he goes let's go
for a ride yeah I know my guys the album
they know they know about the I've
talked enough about the obvious yeah
left on Laurel we are we're already
streaming it anyway we're really excited
about it it's been a really good ride
yeah it's great fun you do this you have
ideas and things that you want to do in
life most time people say Homer direct
movie I'm gonna write this I'm and they
never do it I I'm sure I was that guy
I'm gonna and then one day you're like
why don't we just do it and how good
does that feel when you actually do
something well even when you directed
your movie back in the day today that
was huge that was a huge undertaking and
he did it it was great thank you
what gets in the way don't you think is
how good it is people's response to
things that's always what matters right
that I mean it's not what should matter
what should matter is you accomplish
something right you tell a story you
want to tell you're proud of it you work
hard you work with the people you want
to work with but we always worry about
what others will say afterwards and that
shouldn't be the case you know my friend
name-drop I talk about all the time cuz
I love him but Dax he always has a lot
of good advice I think cuz he's went
through so much hell and you know faced
so much adversity and drugs and all that
[ __ ] but he said you know when his movie
chips didn't do that well I just didn't
do what they wanted in the box office
and certainly back in the day didn't
make you know do do exactly what I
wanted in Y image he goes let me let me
break it down to you dude
if I look at myself in Detroit you know
he's a you know grew up in Michigan well
blond-haired kid and if I said to him as
like a tenure always a ten year old boy
I go hey how do you feel about directing
your own movie in Hollywood and being
the lead actor in it do you think the
kick
would give any [ __ ] about how successful
it was or the money he made all he
thinks immediately is I'm in a movie I
get to direct it Wow it's an inner child
that just comes to life and if it's hard
to keep that because then it gets in the
way like Oh success you know money means
success it doesn't money means happiness
it doesn't right and that's one of the
things that you've always been great at
is not being a child although you but
you enjoy just the fact that you get to
be in this business and do what you do
you don't care about all that other
stuff
well yes to the point but i but I do I
do even though I the goal is to not do
that to just wake up and do something
because you love it and not worry about
what everybody else is thinking about
you you're doing it cuz you love it you
want to do it you walk away and you're
not worrying about I wonder if they
thought it was funny was that good
enough does what they say what they talk
about or what how they feel about what
you did is really it's it shouldn't be
the be-all end-all no but it's there I
know well I think that drives us that
drives us of course yeah well what do
you do I mean how do you how do you
separate them I mean I know look we we
have a little history why don't we get
into that first why don't we just just
the elephant's in the running by the way
yeah this is Ryan no but Laura and I we
met on Smallville and we were just
friends I mean it we she was dating
someone I was dating someone there was
just it was very platonic and and just
cool and I will say you were the only
cast member to cuz I came into the show
season seven and they already had
friends and family and did their own
things and none of the cast hung out
with me and Michael is the only one that
took me t-shirt shopping he reached out
in that way and I thought that was
really nice because the new be well
thank you I always I always feel bad for
guest stars coming on shows especially
after established because there's a
family there and you're already imagined
like you're walking like you're you're
Ryan's girlfriend you're Amanda alright
first time she's walking into Ryan's
family
and you know everybody's doing their
thing Uncle Joe's
you know playing ColecoVision I don't
know what you're doing but you know
everybody's doing the boisterous and she
walks in isn't it nice when Uncle Joe
comes over and goes hey so what you know
just starts talking to her and says oh
let me show you this what some somebody
to reach out because a lot of times
people assume like oh yeah oh that's the
new guest star this week great great who
cares it's fine we don't it's not that
anybody who doesn't like you or it
wasn't no but you're tired you don't
have time to meet a million guest stars
every week or every month so III got it
it was a little scary and strange for me
but you were the one that was like hey
let's go - it was a cherry bomb or
something in vain cherry bomb yeah
sounds provocative but you know it was
one of these cool stores I tried to
franchise it's a franchise so I tried to
my friend Thomas let's open a cherry
bomb in LA I'm like yeah I think we'd
lose money like I've lost that every
investment I've ever made I invested in
a the furniture warehouse in Vancouver
remember the furniture warehouse was
across from the Roxy no these guys are
great damn it's still their big success
story and they dark hey I'm so invest
that what invest is great and so there's
this opportunity and Whistler they're
like hey here it is and this is the
money and I'm telling you this place
folded faster than you could eat I mean
it was like the Millennium Falcon there
and it was gone and I was like wait a
minute what they're like I'm so sorry
Rosie we're gonna get your money back
and I was like I can't how did how did
we lose money that fast there was this a
whole bunch of discrepancies and things
and he says we're gonna get your money
back so it was about eight months later
that my business manager called me Mark
and goes hey we got a two thousand
dollar check from the Furniture
Warehouse
I'm like really two thousand dollars
well we're agent sounds like Harlan
Williams wasn't really body ninety eight
thousand dollars off and then every
month two thousand dollars until I was
paid off and I really commended them and
it was really sweet that they because
most investments you lose you know but
anyway back to that yeah I thought you
were just really sweet and kind and shy
and you you do a lot of you done now
you're getting leave roles but you've
done a lot of guest stars you know I've
never done it I don't think a guest star
in my life better than me
I guess no no it's not a better thing I
I guess I got done a lot I mean at
Canada it's different it's a different
industry in Canada right so I've done a
lot of guest stars growing up but I
think that's good for nerves isn't it no
no it's it's terrible
I thought you'd get better at it like
okay like then in bigger situations you
will be nervous at all
no I mean I can't speak for everyone but
in my case I I don't like going on to a
new set and knowing I'm only there for a
week and not getting a chance to like
know the cast and be a part of the
family it's it's it's like being that
girlfriend that comes in and no one
likes her now that they don't like me
but they don't care to get to know me
because you're leaving so it's that
weird you want to invest in the
character but you don't but you didn't
leave you ended up being there for the
entire season seven yeah right yeah so
that was cool they liked you enough and
eight nine and ten you have a lot of
issues that I have tell me about my
issues Michael well we know about our
era she's like okay look look we dated
we dated alright it took time til you
weren't in a relationship I was in a
relationship we started out as friends
and boom we started dating and it was
great and you know it didn't end up not
working out you're looking at me and not
it I mean who you know it's like I
always tell my friend Shira I'm like
she's like I'll be back she doesn't
cried everything this is just one
particular relationship she's actually
really strong now she's sure I stuck up
for you I sure she doesn't listen to the
podcast she doesn't support me anything
idea but Shira she's like I don't get it
what do I do you know why are you on an
app and they don't respond I might
listen man
99% of the time doesn't work out and
then you get married then you 50% I need
a divorce right so why not just go have
fun and expect it like that this is what
it is let's enjoy it and if it ends it
ends it most likely will end is that
okay that's your problem yeah yeah I
think you're looking at it the wrong way
I am give me a bad advice I'm not asking
for advice no no I'm giving her Bo yes
yes
Ryan do you agree with that run that by
me one more time still stuck on your
Shira impression just it was very sad
well it sure is awesome and she's like
me so we're like the two single people
who call each other at the we our
the night going God what is going on and
I am old there's a reason you shouldn't
be giving her advice then you know what
I mean I've never dated I you're always
always I if I go on a date with you
expect two years at least well that's
what happened that's what happened
because I what is that you just get
hooked I don't know I don't know what it
is I've never been out and someone said
let's go for a drink and I have a drink
and I never see them again I've never
had one-night stand like I've never okay
relationship we'll see maybe that's the
problem with you maybe you're like oh
I'm on a date and it went well so I'll
just date this guy for two years and
then at the end of two years I just keep
going well I mean if you look back in
your relationships and look I you
sometimes you let the good ones go
sometimes you're like [ __ ] why did I let
that one go that I'm not yet so you know
please anyway look it's hard to date in
Los Angeles especially all my friends in
Indiana and my friends in the Midwest
always like dude how do you do it man
it's like it's gotta be hard out there
cuz everybody you know first they say do
they only go out with you because you
know you you were on a show or you're
this and I'm like you know probably
right no I don't think that's true I
think I think ultimately it depends on
the person to if they're looking to get
into the industry they might be dating
you for that reason you know what I mean
it depends on the level they're at it's
it's best for you to not date someone in
this business that's my opinion it is
it's hard to it's hard to date someone
because they have to be so strong
psychological to put up with you put up
with me oh my god oh my god they've got
I need so much attention yeah yeah well
well you know what though I here's the
thing
I have been working on myself a lot and
I feel like what's important is it's a
give and take you know I always have to
be busy I'm like you're not busy but I'm
just my mind's always working I've ATD
you have to sort of accept it this is
who I am but I'm also very giving and
you know I don't maybe I'm wrong am I no
you're that was years ago
it was many years ago that was many
years ago six years ago oh my god
us yeah no more than
I've dated someone for five years I've
been engaged it's been like nine years
if not yeah that was a weird story about
the engagement thing that was the worst
time of my life I was basically
brainwashed
I have no idea what would happen was I
remember oh there's no name it's not
bringing up I remember somebody I bought
the dudes truck yeah and said it was
perfect and this and that and a week
later was in the shop and pretty much it
was in the shop every week and it never
worked
yeah and then I find out that you guys
are yeah it was a weird story how it all
happened it was like kind of friends of
friends friends at friends should not
have introduced us yeah they're like hey
you are yeah oh you don't owe your Laura
broken up I'm like yeah okay cool
it was odd I didn't know at the time it
was bad you know what I mean when you're
in it yeah and also I don't give up on
[ __ ] so yeah give up on us baby we still
love that song David Saul from Starsky
and Hutch saying that last night I know
it's awkward somebody actually wrote in
a tweet once they go breaking the song
and it's just awkward and weird I'm like
yeah well [ __ ] off don't listen it's
[ __ ] me it's what I do then out
Nelson I have no listen to me the next
time alright here's what happened we're
at a con and right before we're gonna go
on stage with you me Tom Welling Kristin
Kreuk all from Smallville some girl goes
did you guys date and right before they
go it was it was like this it's like
yeah he broke up with me a couple times
he broke up with me three times and
Michael rose no no I said three times
and I said every time I left town he
broke up with me and you were like
that's not how it happened we have
different versions of the storm on stage
and you know you always f with me you
know you're always like I enjoy it it is
you you know you always have and that's
that's the good part of our relationship
which is I like you your smart ass and I
think you're an amazing person
you really are you like I look at like
things that you did like in the past
like you made an erv shirt and you got
me this hockey sweatshirt that's
the old-timers is like huff and puff
oculi you know you were really generous
and you're really you know you loved
your family you always want kids you
always talked about kids you were so
jealous in a way of your sister Sara
that you love and you want you know
you're great and to her two kids and
thanks thank you so ever been to me is
it true no I'm kidding
maybe yeah no but I but I was like you
know you're a great person and for
whatever reason that you know it didn't
work you know timing that where I was
where you were take over I don't know
why we didn't work out but I'm still
figuring it I mean I'm 35 now definitely
not where I want to be career-wise and
life wise but you can't control that
stuff you know it's a tough business and
it's especially tough to date in this
town like you said so yeah I still want
kids I still AM married what you just
said something what you said it's um
you're not where you want to be you were
just on a show
bitten well that was a long time ago it
just ended two years ago that was like
three years ago yeah we did three
seasons and that was the show that broke
us up because remember I was here and I
got the offer you probably don't
remember it was nighttime and I was like
I have to decide if I'm gonna take this
and you were like don't take it and then
I was like [ __ ] you I'm gonna take it
well hang on hang on hang on this is not
fair this is wrong you said they're
offering me [ __ ] money the scripts not
even that great I don't really want to
move there
I gave me all these I think that's the
case in my life you say look if you
would have said Michael I love the
script I love the idea I love the
character it's good all these things I'm
like yes well to be fair to the audience
that likes the show and I actually ended
up really loving it they they wrote the
character became stronger you know like
backtrack on not saying that no no I'm
not dissing the show I'm saying that in
the beginning you were I wasn't sure but
I I guess I was asking for your advice
what happens as you say I want your
honest opinion don't ever give your
honest opinion Ryan I want to know you
know you tell me am i fat you are absent
my mom once said Michael I'm your mother
I love you I know you'll be honest with
me is my
fact is do these jeans make my ass look
fat like a mom your ass makes your ass
look fat sorry guys if somebody if I
looked at you Laura physically like I
want you to look at me and if I said
Laura do I have a big head be honest
yeah thank you I have a big head in
Spanish that's your thing go get on the
cabeza and ego no no I get on you're
supposed to I don't know are you
uncomfortable a little bit are you no I
mean I mean you guys seem okay with it
i I we've gotten to a point where we're
fine you guys are you guys are fine with
it I am new to this I just you know I
feel like I have to mediate it for some
reason no no we are a completely
different personality yeah and maybe
that's why it worked when it did yeah
but like there's like right now there's
not a nerve in my body there's not like
any resentment there's no dislike
there's just like this is joy that's fun
to me this is fun talking to you openly
and I'm not in the I don't feel weird if
I thought it was gonna be weird like
there's some ex-girlfriends I would not
have come in here right you I felt like
I like Laura she's cool she texts me
when the ER was sick I've never been an
[ __ ] to you you should have been in
the in love podcast in love with Michael
Rosenbaum and Chris Sullivan that
podcast is more about relationships and
honestly I think one of the reasons that
we're okay now is we had the first time
we had seen each other in years was in
Paris at a convention and I was like of
course it's like the city of love and I
have to see that guy because I was still
like I don't know how I feel about this
and then we were fine and I was like oh
I enjoy you know pokin Adam yeah we're
still smartasses with each other I
wasn't sure I don't have that
relationship with anyone else so I enjoy
that
yeah I do too that was it was nice and I
remember especially on the stage if I
can like throw you under the bus it's I
mean you do constantly yeah
yeah but I noticed like people would say
dude is that gonna be weird I'm like I I
don't know
and then after Paris I go wasn't where
at all yeah I think we're both good
sports and we're both a little more
mature you deftly more mature than I am
all right let's get into this so you're
you almost died as a kid by the way I
did spina bifida no Julia now what does
that mean what happens when you have
bacterial meningitis
well I the story they tell me when I was
born my sister was getting her tonsils
out and she wasn't supposed to come hear
me because she had a bacteria my sister
came over to meet me in the hospital and
jealous sister coughed on me
well she had this bacterial ibi
developed bacterial meningitis and I was
in the hospital for months and swelling
on the brain I was paralyzed on the left
side of my body and they had to drain
the liquid from my brain and I guess you
know as my mom says they they told her
one day that if you're if her
temperature doesn't go down we're gonna
have to give her this medication of
sorts that will either make her blind or
deaf if her temperature goes down we
won't give it to her and the next
morning my temperature dropped and they
didn't give me that drug otherwise I
would be blind or deaf right now but I
had a learning disability from the
meningitis my whole life that's
something that I had to like work
through myself there's no cure for that
you just find other ways to in school I
would just memorize textbooks I didn't
actually fully understand everything I
memorized it so I could get straight A's
so you find your own way and I think
that's why I went into acting because it
was memorization it was becoming someone
that you're not
I was always embarrassed in school like
they'd pull me out for testing I had
these surveyors that followed me for
years through like elementary school so
yeah it really [ __ ] with who I was as
a kid but sort of made me who I am now
Jesus yeah I mean I remember some stuff
that you've told me but that and when
you say a learning disability as a kid I
always felt like I was just stupid I
couldn't comprehend things I'd read
things and I just because of the ATD and
hey like when you went you so you could
quickly memorize things but you wouldn't
be able to comp like absorb them I did
it depends what it was there was a lot
that I was able to fully understand and
absorb and was very much into but things
like I couldn't tell time I didn't
understand a clock are you looking for a
clock right now that's right time math
I'm directionally challenged still like
I have I still write no not like that
but like manorath or so I just I'm it's
very different for me and there are a
lot of people who have the same
disability where you it's not like
you're dyslexic but you have trouble and
you flip things so my whole life my goal
was to appear to be like everyone else
right which [ __ ] with you when you're
trying to be like everyone else and not
yourself so that now as an adults I
still struggle with people I'm I to I
don't want them to think of me
differently but at the same time I want
to be who I it's it's a weird thing it
definitely molded me in a way that I'm
insecure about stuff I have social
anxiety alright alright so here's the
thing though I feel though when you are
in something you're unlike for instance
if I go to a premiere or if I had to
take pictures I'm uncomfortable I jump
in - I can't dance mechanism a character
yeah just to make myself comfortable are
me I'm gonna do it I can so I can be
comfortable because I'm not gonna let
this take over yeah but there are those
times when I'm then I'm just like oh I
get through it and I feel good now I'm
like okay I'm okay now do you feel like
when you go to a premiere you do these
things like I don't want to be here I
don't like this and then there's a
moment really connect with someone I'm
good now that person saved me in a way I
like them I would say for myself it's
similar and that I need to put on a
character not a character but it just
can't be myself and I'm not like you
whereas the characters loud and she has
energy my character is like just calmly
get through this put on my like Sasha
Fierce version of myself and then my
first thing when I go into an event is
like I want to figure out how to leave
as soon as possible you want to just get
out of there yeah I want to find the
quickest exit and and it doesn't really
matter what the event is or You Know Who
I know there it's it's a job do you feel
like you belong no I mean I don't think
anybody does though do you I have been
fighting with this for a long time where
I just never feel comfortable with who I
am I never feel like I'm accepted I
never fit in and Joe lo Truglio who's on
the show yesterday he's on Brooklyn
nine-nine he's an old friend of mine he
starts saying you have to stop it what
he does now because he always felt like
he didn't belong and that's how I've
always felt
he's like but you're here which means
you belong
stop get out of your way it doesn't
matter if you're around people that you
think are oh they're bigger stars or
this you belong where you are see that's
crazy to me that you think you don't
belong because that's crazy for me too
bad that you don't belong but I would
say I've been very open about that like
I'm introverted I talk about that
whereas you come across as someone who's
comfortable in every situation you walk
in a room you're the loudest guy now I
understand that that's your safety
mechanism which is crazy I I think I
shut down and you rev up to survive
that's interesting yeah Ryan's nodding
like you [ __ ] know Ryan don't talk to
me no I sat down - yeah like right now
you seem like you are you shutting down
me I'm shutting down yeah are you like
c-3po guys don't fight inside of you is
brought to you by Sleep Number stop
folks you're talking to some dude who's
had seven spine surgeries and I know
what comfort is and no other bed has
helped me out like Sleep Number period
the end the Sleep Number bed has done
everything for me and if you're thinking
about getting the bed quit wasting your
money and other stuff Sleep Number
allows me to adjust on each side of the
bed and since I'm single most of my life
I could put it at 85 which is pretty
nice and stiff and then I could put it
at a nice 25 I want to sleep on a cloud
I tend to roll back and forth to each
side of the bed throughout the night I
also have this what do you call it when
it just brings you up you know it's a
button it's his turn upright position so
I can meditate in the morning I think
that's the legal term for it that's what
I'm gonna call it because this is my
personal experience I want to talk about
my personal experience in Sleep Number
and I'm gonna give it to him the Sleep
Number 360 smart bed senses your
movements in the middle of the night
automatically adjust to keep you
sleeping comfortably throughout the
night sleep IQ technology inside the bed
of tracks that you're sleeping gives you
personalized insights for your best
sleep these guys take it seriously they
take sleep seriously quality sleep is
essential as we all know I have anxiety
I don't sleep well
it helps you wake up in the morning
rested you got what do you have Ryan you
have your sanity you have your optimal
health don't you oh yeah I mean you ever
wake up and you just feel scatterbrained
especially around the holidays now yeah
oh it was that rhetorical yeah I don't
know as soon as I feel like I'm angry
about it because it's so important in
people you know I go to my grandmother's
house and I'm like I can't sleep on your
F in bed
I say F and I don't say the bad word you
know swearing for new grandma I said I
love you I want to stay with you I want
to be here for you no but I want to I
want to be comfortable I'll just leave
my owner
your mattress was from 1960 let you
understand and I don't want this these
other mattresses these phonies out there
I don't want to go to a random
department store and describe mattress
cuz it's new I want to be comfortable so
I could get my grandmother as much love
as possible does it make sense Ryan that
total sense Sleep Number they've I've
always been a big fan I hope they
continue to be my sponsor make spirits
bright this holiday season with gifts
for quality sleep a Sleep Number 360
smart bed adjust on each side to give
all a good night
from $9.99 only at a Sleep Number store
or Sleep Number dot-com slash inside
that Sleep Number dot-com slash inside
get yourself a bed oh yeah inside of you
is brought to you by honey I have honey
and I love it it's such a no-brainer I
can't even tell you what you're missing
do you know that honey has found it's
over 10 million members over a billion
dollars in savings honey has over a
hundred thousand five star reviews on
the Google Chrome store I I'm set enough
you want to get items cheaper honey is a
free browser extension that
automatically finds the best promo codes
whenever you shop online this means you
always get the best deals without even
trying on over 20,000 sites such as
Amazon j.crew eBay Expedia etc if you're
buying gifts this holiday season you
need honey if you're not you probably
know someone who is so do them a solid
and tell them about honey honey can help
make sure
that you're getting the best price for
whatever you're buying and it's free
come on it's free I'm not selling
anything it's free it's just two clicks
away get honey for free at join honey
dot-com
slash IOU inside of you is brought to
you by what a great product I have so
much this stuff around my house uncommon
apothecary anybody who knows look put it
this way Ryan yeah said something when
you came into the house today yeah this
isn't this isn't staged folks well I
found out my parents are into CBD oil
and I mentioned uncommon apothecary and
I told about the discount and now they
have it and they love it they ordered it
they did and it's cheaper than the stuff
they were using before and better and
better I love this stuff I really love
this stuff everybody I this is a true
story I went to Florida to visit my
grandmother because I lost my
grandfather and I'm sitting there with
her old friends
this guy Larry great guy he was a
pianist it was like one of those movies
where you think this isn't real and he
goes I don't play piano because my
fingers I can't move them around I got
arthritis
I took them this old man's hand and I
rubbed this uncommon apothecary all over
deeply into his fingers and his joints
thirty Seconds he goes Michael look at
this he starts moving his fingers like I
was like I was Jesus I'm like what the
come on Larry is I don't I'm it made
everything comfortable it's a cooling
feeling Larry can move his hands if we
had a piano he probably would have
belted out a couple of Beethoven you
didn't go get him a piano in that moment
I should have but that's a true story I
swear to God on everything that's a true
story
I wish you can call Larry and talk to
him CBD is from the hemp plant unlike
its sister Mary Jane CBD contains less
than 0.3 percent THC meaning it's not
gonna get you high uncommon apothecary
is the real deal folks
unlike many so called CBD products and
Amazon and other online shopping sites
uncommon apothecary products or
third-party tested to ensure quality
consistency and the results are posted
right on the site it's legal without
prescription in all 50 states and I just
love this Ryan tell Mort ahead to you a
dash CBD calm
I'd use the code inside 20 at checkout
to receive 20% off for inside of you
listeners and see why thousands are
switching from prescriptions to a more
natural alternative that's very true
you a - CBD dot-com and you use the code
inside 20 for every item purchased on
common apothecary will donate $1 to
local homeless shelters UA - CBD com use
the code inside 20 you know I'm very
open about my learning disability about
being introverted about struggling I
mean being a woman in this industry all
that [ __ ]
I'm 35 I haven't figured out anything
out I know you have had people on your
show and there are women who say you
know I finally figured it out I meditate
I do yoga like I had a vision board
that's great
I've done that and I still don't know
what the [ __ ] okay hang on all right
first of all there's nobody on this show
I think that has ever said I figured it
out but I don't think I don't think you
ever figured out I think at the very end
you're hoping for some sort of peace
some sort of understanding or acceptance
within yourself that says you know what
I was a good person mm-hmm I really
tried to help people I tried to listen I
wasn't always good at it but I did try
and I got better I tried to improve
myself
I tried to respect this place that I
lived this beautiful earth this universe
whatever you believe I don't have to get
in religion but like there's all these
things where you go you know what I am
okay with my life I was yeah and so
right now if I was about to die it's a
oh my god I don't I can't I couldn't say
all I could say is this if I was dying
right now watch I'll die and then in
this elastic oh my god how profound I'm
not saying that people figure it out I
think what which you hit on is that we
don't figure things out but we get to a
place where we accept where we are and
we're happy with that that's the thing
right that's see that makes sense and
and I don't think I'm there okay and
maybe give yourself some sort of what's
the word Brian did get the dictionary
out you know
not big with words dude I'm gonna pick
with words you have to give yourself a
you have to give yourself some everybody
right now is thinking of the world they
know the word and I'm coming up you just
have to give yourself a little bit more
credit or yes leeway little space oh hey
yeah good yourself so every day is
different different in this [ __ ] City
which I don't like is like Sunday that
person who tweeted me is now really out
of there out but though if I if some if
I was on my deathbed right now God
willing I'm not I would say man I wish I
would have loved more I wish I would
have listened more I know that I was on
the right track I know that I was really
trying and it was the beginning of a new
me and boy I wish I had more time
because now I really see the light and I
really see what I'm supposed to do I
really see that there is a purpose for
me so that's what I would say right now
which is better than if I was to die
maybe a year ago and I got a knock on
wood stop saying okay but you know
there's no around here what the [ __ ]
from what stuff I'm sitting in a wooden
chair but you know maybe you're going to
sit Oh what what I don't even know what
am i what am i doing
I don't even what's your middle name
Diane Wow yeah I remember that or did
you like look at that up last night well
adjusted
okay thank you Jess I knew your middle
names Diane or Jess how do I spell it
dia and you know I wanted to say I want
to say another end but ideas write
another any yeah thank you my middle
names actually I was named after Diana
Ross no cousin of mine that committed
suicide
well downhill yep well your parents
really that's like naming their daughter
are their Paris or something like a big
name it's the opposite effect
my middle name is Old Yeller so no but I
mean they're naming you what is he in
it's named after a cousin of mine that I
never met so they're naming you after
someone who killed himself
yeah that's Condon but it was in memory
of and it's beautiful thing it is a
beautiful yeah what's also dark is that
my you know my last name is Vandervoort
we just actually it's exciting my cousin
just had a boy Austin Vandervoort so
he's the first man in the family that's
gonna finally carry on the name because
we've only had women in the family so um
totally off topic but hi Austin I hope I
meet you soon look at that I mean you're
35 yeah I know you've always wanted kids
you still want kids yeah I know you just
shouldn't even ask a girl it's different
cuz I know you so I could say hey you
said of course you want kids and all
that stuff well you know you're young
still you are I'm 47 I'm running out of
time not as a man no no no [ __ ] do you
realize if I have a child right now
let's say I have a kid and by the time
I'm 50 that means we all do you 47 yeah
but when my kids 20s just say 20 it's
easy I'm like 70 yeah that's like that's
not as a fair I guess I mean what's fair
but you're also young at heart so you
would have a lot of fun with them you
play with them you know who knows if
I'll be able to move around
I'm our dude I'll tell you I woke up
Monday morning just walked in and I had
a huge fight with my band you know we
just got infinitely left and Laura might
be our first and only helping the folks
albums available everywhere you know I
had having problems with my upper back I
played some softball and then tennis and
then I you know I'm just like trying to
you know I'm getting back in shape and
then I woke up Monday I couldn't get out
of bed I was like Frankenstein i sat in
my massage chair massage chair for like
eight years now it's the same one I
always feel bad now because Ryan
Reynolds no Ryan Gosling goose Gosling
costly new slang both beautiful Canadian
my beautiful men they he in this movie
he had a massage chair and everybody
laughed like oh how cheesy I was like oh
my god I have a massage chair I remember
thinking that when I watch the movie I'm
like but I've had seven back surgeries I
need this little bit anyway so yes being
getting old does suck and be living in
pain sucks and that's one thing you've
been pretty good at you might have had
some [ __ ] going on when you're young but
you're a healthy woman you know knock on
wood you and I look at you and you do
have a great career hey Eddie cake
you do you you're the lead role and
stuff you were in V you're in Smallville
you had a three-episode arc on Supergirl
I think we forget I have a new Netflix
show coming out you have a new Netflix
show coming out coming out produced and
and and and starred in a movie with
you're the Penson yeah Canadian actor
he's a legend in Canada right and then
movies called dis age of dysphoria just
I get dysphoria I just kind of skimmed
stuff and then I I've been wanting to
work with Gordon Pinsent since I was 12
he was my mentor and I had never worked
with him he's 88 now so I developed a
movie really with the goal of just
working with Gordon and it's a beautiful
film we're really proud of it please go
see that guys she worked really hard on
Anna she's been talking about it for a
while and it's annoying Michael oh it
doesn't annoy me and what I'm saying if
you just listen to this conversation
right now if you just hear yourself you
know because I'm dwelling on what you
said of about eight minutes ago you said
you know I'm not where I want to be my
career I'm not where I wanna be this if
you just take a step back just take a
[ __ ] stand I'm when I speak to you
it's like I'm looking in a mirror
because I need to do this Ryan you need
to do this no matter where we are where
you are you're where you're supposed to
be don't forget to like I'm telling
myself this and telling everybody out
there look look guys don't forget to
live in the moment you're not your work
when you work you work and if you just
are always absorbed with what what else
am I gonna get how much money can I get
how much you're never going to live in
the moment life is going past you yeah
that's a you pervert no I understand I
understand for me as a Canadian living
in Los Angeles it's hard for me to live
here I don't know if it's the same for
you because you're not from here but
you've been here longer than I have
I moved here to work and this entire
city is all this industry and there's no
escape from it when I landed I went to
Sammy's camera to print a picture of my
beautiful dog and there's three actors
behind me talking about everything that
they've booked and that's great but I
don't want to hear about it when I'm
just in my like you know what I mean
it's that constant reminder gonna hi
you don't have to hear these people
there's always gonna be people around I
know I know but I'm just saying in
Toronto it's it's a totally different oh
I'm gonna move back yeah you are I am
now you're dating someone I know we're
not gonna talk about that we're not I
know or not where's he from
he famiglia he's from LA yeah so he's
aware of that that you want to go back
to Toronto yeah we'll leave it at that
Ryan now yo Ryan how Ronnie Ronnie
Ryan Ronnie Ronnie Ronnie Ronnie Oviedo
the ones and twos Ronnie hey
Ryan's 31 he's four years younger now
I'm not saying this because you're not
ungrateful because you are grateful Ryan
is extraordinarily talented he's funny
he can sing he's always working he's
editing he's doing comedy he's doing
everything now he's engineering my show
right now do you think he's hit the peak
of his life do you think this is what he
wants to do for his life I wish it was I
wish that the show gets so big that I
could pay him so much money that Ryan
would just love working with me every
day we'd be the next Kevin and being but
I know in my heart
Ryan would love to get a show he would
love to get a movie and that's what he's
going for
now Ryan are you able to sit there and
take a moment go ahead I know what I
need to do this is not what I want to do
right now or I'm just gonna do can you
enjoy things in the moment oh you don't
know this isn't the pinnacle of what I
wanted to do also they look on the
internet it's like I just want to work
for Michael Rosenbaum I hope someday he
has a podcast but I could I was playing
a long game I hope his other engineer
could quit no I mean I honestly this has
been like a sort of an interesting
transition or a year for me I sort of
got opened up like a the company I was
working for one totally bankrupt and so
then I have sort of had a year of
self-reflection and just sort of needed
to pick up some gigs and Michael was
kind enough to let me you know do this
well I continued to work on other stuff
and it's fun does he annoy you well no
no I really enjoyed this has been a lot
of fun it is fun I love having you here
and you know it wasn't one of those
things where I you said you just said
something like Michael you know gave me
this opportunity the reason I wanted him
to be here is because first of all half
my duties are tonight it's this
therapeutic thing that my friends come
over and we just have our tonight so
Ryan started coming with Amanda his
girlfriend and all my friends and I by
the way I've known Ryan for a couple
years now and I always liked Ryan and
then I was like [ __ ] I need an engineer
and did you say did you mention it or
how did it happen
Amanda might have ushered me towards it
because she's good about that yeah I
think she said something like well if
you need an engineer some Rago Ryan do
you want to do that like sure it's like
a [ __ ] yeah let's do it
it was just like that and within a week
right it was he's learning how to do it
and he's in like seven episodes already
Wow
so had you done a lot of this before
then or you were yeah yeah I'd done this
before so you weren't necessarily
learning as you went on this I mean this
is sort of a different format than I'm
used to right but it's pretty
straightforward yeah but you know the
cool thing is is Ryan is like hey this
just happened and I'm enjoying this and
it's fun and I'm learning a lot and I
mean and who knows what will happen
after this like I said I'm definitely
one of those you know I took that India
gram and you find out what you are you
should take an angiogram everybody I
should I've talked about it I think
before but it tells you what you are you
just be honest with all the questions
and I'm a helper I'm a loyalist and I'm
an enthusiast and so a helper it's not
that I want to help but to me I'm like
[ __ ] not only do I want to succeed in
this podcast that you can get bigger and
bigger but man what if this was a
full-time job for Ryan and I can hang
out with him all the time or somebody
buys it and inside he's on TV and Ryan's
my [ __ ] Ed McMahon
or maybe I'm his dad McMahon you're
always hoping things work yeah you know
what works for you what are you like
going you know what lauric good for you
I'm proud of you and I'm good with this
that's a heavy question it's not that
hard well no it is hard I'm I'm my
family is the best part of my life for
sure I'm very close with them
it that's a tough question for someone
who doesn't feel like they figured it
out yet so but you said it but I I am
proud of what I've done I've started off
as a kid doing in this business and I
had to grow up really quickly because I
wanted to match the adults on set I
wanted to be perfect I wanted to be
memorized and professional but one thing
that I really wish I had done was
enjoyed more of my childhood because I
took it so seriously
I didn't start enjoying what I do for a
living
probably until six years ago so now I'm
learning to enjoy it and to not try to
just like be perfect like I enjoyed
Smallville
I enjoyed moments of it but the whole
time I was like don't puck up don't get
fired
like me yeah I was playing Supergirl
like there was a lot of people that
wanted specific things from me and not
just the producers the audience like I
wanted to be that person like you and
Tom wanted to be those characters
perfectly for that audience but also
have your own spin on it and I just I
think I struggled with that pressure I
was 17 so 18 you know when we dated I
felt like because I'm such a kid I I saw
you open up and have fun I think you
were learning how to have fun yeah
that's exactly what it was and I there's
a weird part of me that's like if I'm
truly laughing or smiling I feel like
I'm not allowed to do this like I have
to that's why I started drinking you
drinking now yeah yeah yeah really drink
before and there was no reason that I
didn't do it other than I wanted to be
in control and now it's you know I'll
have sake or you known alcoholic no no
like oh I'll have a drink and that
allows me to you know I'm allowed to
have fun I'm allowed to enjoy this
because I didn't really know how to do
that
I like this conversation I didn't really
know exactly where it would go or what
but I like that you're opening up I like
that that's just a great quality is
being vulnerable and I'm doing that this
this show is giving me that opportunity
but you also have to give yourself that
opportunity whatever that is to to be
vulnerable my therapist said I want you
to just feel I want you to be vulnerable
I want you to feel I want you to love I
want eat it and it was just like what
what what what do you mean so the other
night I'm watching a movie at Horne
it's what my friends as you know and
there's this movie I get emotional at
the end no these other guys are kind of
like laughing or talking or whatever and
Rob's like Rossum bombs crying again and
he's just kidding but I was like you
guys want that's really sweet moment
they both lost their mother all these
kids died and I know it sounds horrible
but like I was I was a little emotional
wasn't bawling but I I'm let allowing
myself I used to like right when I felt
that you know that feeling where they
hit your nose and right in between your
eyes that that first that like little
beginnings of like little like I could
cry thing and but now Mike I used to be
like stop go go other way and then
you're out of it you're allowing it to
come out but I just want to embrace
moments where I could just feel where I
could let it go in fact I said to my
therapist can i I asked her can I can't
like a kid can I like watch a sad movie
once in a while and cry just just to get
cries out I feel like I was eight years
old she's like yes but please don't do
it every day so I go I go she goes well
what movie I go I know right now there's
two when Hobson dies in the movie Arthur
you know and that's his dad that's
always really been his dad even though
it's not his dad it says you know
somebody who's at the at the mansion who
takes care of Butler you know and you
know it's like it's it was kind of in
its you never see him get emotional and
they both sort of were a little
emotional like they know this is the end
that moment and then there's a couple of
moments in Rocky do you cry a lot
yeah you do yeah how often lately like
every day what makes you cry being alone
you deflecting oh yeah yeah listen I so
I had I had a massage last night and I
don't know if I ever introduced you to
this woman but I think you should use
her Tommy uses her now I introduced her
to Tom Nicole lazing her talk about that
after all she does well she does Reiki
as well but I I had her over last night
and we were talking about meditation I
said I've never know
how to do it I die I'm gonna fall asleep
or I can't shut this off and I don't
want to sit alone with what's going on
in here my mind she said well how do you
tap into emotions for work like there
must be a meditation there I said no
literally if I have an experience I put
it in a box and that's that box for when
I need to act that way on camera these
are my tear boxes these are my happy
joyful boxes she's like some meditation
is opening up all of those boxes at once
and just feeling it and so that's what
you're reminding me of is just like your
therapist said let it just let it happen
like I don't I've never watched the
notebook because I don't want to deal
with it was she watchin ya seen it or
did you cry no no what that was Ball
State University kept dating my
grandparents what makes you cry when you
cry from um most I mean don't say
Bladerunner like Coco God not come to
think of that cry a lot I don't cry a
lot but that I made me cry up made me
see of course of course Paul also
there's just a lot of songs on the radio
now if they were if you relate to it
like for me crying when I'm driving um
so all right so you do cry a lot you're
in your head you don't like being alone
that's what it is you do not like being
a lot I like being physically alone for
a couple days because I'm an introvert
and I need my space and I like my
routine but in life I need to be
connected to someone or family so la is
a very like I have a place here that I
bought I live by myself my dogs not here
right now so walking in the door to
quiet was nice for a second and then
it's like hell you know what I mean I'm
sure you're the same way you always have
to have something going on you know you
need a pair of keys again this isn't me
giving advice although it cuz sorta is
because my advice is you know my advice
was my the best advice somebody gave me
and I still haven't conquered it yet my
psychiatrist looked at me his old guy
with a beard
beautiful man the first time I've ever
felt safe with someone and I remember
the first eight sessions he's like
we can get very this is difficult it's
not that cut and dry with you it is it
does a lot of things going on you got
the child you got this thing we could be
I haven't but get in there just bear
with me we're gonna get that we're gonna
find you know it was that thing where
he's very honest that wasn't like okay
and then he said something like in the
last two sessions you know what you know
what you need
here's Michael all of this stuff I'm
gonna share this this guy is a thousand
dollars a day okay it's expensive as
[ __ ] I mean thank God I somehow could
afford it but I I know that I needed to
go to the best I know that I needed to
really break through and have
breakthrough cereal and I was my I'm the
investment that the most important
investment nothing matters if I'm happy
and fulfilled and I purpose and feel
these things I'd rather be if somebody
said you're broke well it's not a
furniture store that you're investing in
that goes under it's yourself million
percent 100 percent he says I want you
to be in love I want you to love I want
you to the hardest part Michael though
he said is for you to accept love that
you're worthy of being loved and and it
was really like as you guys were looking
at me I'm sure Ryan's looking down isn't
he's uncomfortable but you know what he
was it because if you think about you
like what that's so simple that it's not
but how could I
but how is he so right with something so
simple this is this is what he did this
is what he gave me this is the therapy
this is and the same day I had another
session with this other woman with this
woman and she goes I think once you
really fall in love and allow yourself
to be loved and it's gonna be very
difficult I go wait a minute are you
talking the doctor tesslar are you guys
she said what no what are you talking
about I go he said the same thing
because well he also said all this stuff
right now is is [ __ ] it's great
you're in movies you have a podcast you
have this you're writing scripts you
have a great life whatever but all that
stuff it's all [ __ ] do you know what
isn't [ __ ] what what human beings
need is we need love
we want to be loved we want to feel
loved we want to feel safe we want to be
in love and to love and that that is the
most I think your you will thrive if you
could allow and it will be difficult
because you'll look for things I don't
know that know look he said there are
red flags and those red flags oh this
person's an alcoholic oh this person's a
drug addict or ho this person is a feet
whatever it is there's a red flag things
in one person right or it's but if it's
things like Oh her toes bigger than the
other who gives a [ __ ] yeah I think
you're really picky because you're
looking he says I'm looking at myself
right if you really enjoy someone and
you really trust them and you feel safe
it's a beautiful thing yeah and I think
being alone and by the way I took a I
sort of I did something that was a test
to myself I tried to be alone a lot I
tried to not always work and I started
becoming more of a hermit I noticed that
the depression got worse and the anxiety
get worse that could understand it's
like are you that [ __ ] up that you
can't be alone dude and the reality is
that being alone is not always a good
thing and if you don't have structure in
your life if you don't have routine in
your life not you or you Ryan all of us
will go [ __ ] bananas if you wake up
ago what am I gonna do today you'll end
up doing nothing you already filled
you'll be depressed so what I do on
Sundays I plan the week out here's my
calendar if you look in my office you're
gonna see that I'm crazy people will go
why do you have three calendars even
Jess is like what are you doing I have a
little one for the week I have a bigger
one chalkboard for the month and I have
my other one that if I let have to look
in the car with what I'm doing so I
always know what's going on and I
structure it
hey I don't many podcast this week I
should book a podcast I should make sure
cuz I'm ahead of the game I have like
eight or ten episodes you know what
let's find well let's you know what
you're gonna work out on this day you
know what you're gonna set up a meeting
and talk about this animated series you
know what you are going to meditate
every day
of your [ __ ] life you were gonna do
and when you have structure and routine
which I just didn't I let all that go
you'll [ __ ] go bananas yeah
do you have structure I'm st. as you I
make sure that I have it because you'll
go bananas yeah I especially being here
if I'm not busy working I know I'm
taking meetings I'm trying to develop
three films right now so I make sure
there's a balance you know working out
hiking with friends all of that stuff
but there you know night time you're by
yourself and that's the time that you
reflect on your day and that can go
either way is your career so important
to you where you want to act for the
rest of your life or could you sit live
a simple life could you honestly someone
said let's go move to a small town or
whatever and just figure it out and get
away from everything or are you someone
that just needs you love acting you'd
love all this you have to do this I
would say it's 50/50 I love to get away
and escape this but there's a part of me
that this is all that I've ever done
this I've acted my whole life so I
wouldn't say that I love acting
I love being busy and being productive
and developing and creating projects so
I'm 5050 I could move away to a small
town and never do this again but I might
drive myself crazy unless I find another
passion that feels productive every day
because I I can't even go on vacation
for more than two days and chill the eff
out because I start going oh I should be
doing this I should be doing that oh I
have this idea I should take that
meeting you know I think similar to you
we have to force ourselves to take that
time and then can't do a lot of that
because it's also not healthy you know I
noticed I was doing my friend Rob's
birthday was his fortieth birthday happy
birthday dancing hey I was at his little
party last night
small gathering and I know some emails
came up and you know I was at the dinner
table when everybody's kind of talking
and I kind of started looking at my
phone and I was like oh I gotta respond
to that I respond to that and then I
stopped about five minutes him and I go
this is your best friend's birthday this
is a person who makes your life better
get off the [ __ ] phone it's not
important your
isn't saying they need to know right
this [ __ ] second about nothing is
that important what's important memories
connections love and that's what I'm
working on I'm working on all these
little things like God the phone isn't
it amazing what the phone can do if we
didn't have these cell phones and by the
way they're great in so many ways
because I talk to my grandparents but
god bless man if we didn't have these
we're always on them yeah from the time
we wake up to the time again
so I'm trying to eliminate as much as I
can it should not be the first thing you
look at in the morning or the last thing
you look at it it's not in the morning
I've done that I fixed that I did not
look at my phone to an hour in after I
do all my chores and all that stuff but
at night I've got to stop that I was
reading for a while I got to go back to
reading phone goes off at 10:00 done I
was told that there and I have to look
into it on the iPhone there's the
ability to at a certain time your blue
light on your phone can turn off so if
you do look at your phone you're not
stimulated by the blue light I think
everybody knows that well that's new to
me do you um do you take any kind of
medication - - for depression and
anxiety or anything no no never never
have I tried when I first moved to LA
depression medication didn't work for me
because I I was like a zombie I couldn't
memorize my auditions I just felt like I
wasn't on it so I stopped that I've
taken nothing except tequila shots
sometimes sometimes it's kill shot as
long as it's not like five every time
but that's not true I've done the CBD
pens this has been great
look what's going on right now in with
work developing a lot of stuff like what
was important to you that you're working
on right now or that you want to get
going or that you have the Netflix
series so you have a Netflix series
viewers V Wars what's that about
vampires vampires again again I've never
done vampires this is a new thing it was
bitten werewolf werewolves [ __ ] remember
remember uh will be doing the shadows
werewolves knots werewolves yes I'm
swearing it so that's funny gonna be a
vampire well I can't say if I am or I'm
not one oh yeah
and who's in anybody now in Somerhalder
Adrian home dude all right hang on a
second hang on a second
who was on smoke yeah I love Adrian okay
awesome I've first time I worked with
Adrian was like nine years ago on a
movie called damage in love Adrian he's
fantastic he's my loan he's number two
on that show what are you gonna do you
realize how big that shows gonna be I
hope it does well in summer Holder has
such a huge following he's good but he
has billions of followers this show is
gonna get seen you're gonna go to
conventions and people are gonna get mob
you that's just the reality you I'm
telling you when this comes out I'm just
remember this conversation
it's just vampires he did vampire
diarrhea diaries and no no it's true
that brings me back to conventions when
you make the signer do the diarrhea over
and over again
have you seen tell the audience about
that most annoying thing you know I do
it for Tom Tom Tom Tom loves us arguing
and the hearing-impaired love it
wait okay so there's always an
interpreter or a signer on stage when
we're doing conventions and I think the
first time you did it it was funny he
repeated diarrhea over and over again so
she had to keep doing that symbol and
everyone thought it was great and then
he's done it at every convention that
non verbal diarrhea dire hands whipping
down the first time Kristen did a
convention with you and she texted me
after and I was like did you survive she
was like oh my god the diarrhea thing I
mean we all think it's funny but
remember the last time you did it I was
like fine new material you know yeah but
people love you we love you you know you
entertain us
thank God you take over the the Q&A is
because Tom and I couldn't do it without
you I love that you know you know I love
mostly about Tom is that you know a lot
of actors every time I did an interview
with another actor for a show or a movie
they'd always I could tell they feel
like they're being upstaged because I
just go on and they and I could tell
they don't like it and it makes me
uncomfortable which makes me then not
want to be my
self but when I'm with Tom he says
[ __ ] do your thing dude [ __ ] do it
yeah [ __ ] do it
and their sake tell some people like no
he's upstaging me I'm not meaning to I'm
just having [ __ ] fun ok so can I just
refer back to what we talked to at the
beginning of this podcast you said
you're uncomfortable with those things
so you put on your personality right but
then you just said I'm being myself up
there people just need to be okay little
Juvonen
they are q and A's are different because
when you're in a convention the people
are there to see you so so it's not
uncomfortable because they're there to
see you you know why you're there but
when you go to like an event or
something about people you don't know
and you're like I don't know what am I
supposed to you just but immediately
when I'm on stage late Michael Rosenbaum
they are asking me questions and I'm
gonna run with it
yeah and and I don't I don't feel like
you're upstaging at all like Tom and I
love that you do that because we can
just laugh and like watch the show every
time but there are moments where you
know for instance I wanted to talk about
age or dysphoria or viewers I think the
convention or the the panel is over I
think the last one we were at and we
were getting up to walk away and I was
like [ __ ] it and I grabbed the mic I'm
like and then I just said the things
that I wanted to talk about within like
two minutes you know what though you
know what though next time we do one
together
I had the fact you're also great when I
don't get any questions because everyone
loves you and Tom and I completely
understand that I'm lucky that I get to
do this with you guys because I only did
a couple seasons but you're really great
about asking the audience to ask me
questions always I appreciate always
because I yeah I think they really would
you want to hear it they get caught up
but I'm like you know Lord did this real
or anything
I always always that always means a lot
to me because there will be times at
panels that I don't say a lot and I'm
okay with that because I'm a fan I was a
fan of Smallville before I was on it I
want to hear what you guys have to say
and you know you're really nice to have
the audience remember that you know
we're doing Tom and I doing this thing I
know I came up with this idea called
Smallville Nights and so it's just Tom
and I and we do this I can't tell you
but some so we it's at night after the
conventions over and we do this our
thing I can tell you afterwards what we
do but it's unlike anything we do at the
QA there
some things that we do that will never
be done and we don't want any cameras or
video or you'll never come back to one
of these things again so it's a moment
that you'll remember and you'll have fun
and it's like a I was gonna ask you this
I know now it's a little space in
between but you know you work you worked
with Allison have you talked about this
on your podcast um a little bit not a
lot but what was your relationship with
her and did you see did you like when
people ask me I'm like uh you know I
just thought she was a really sweet girl
who needed attention like every actor
and but she you know I who would ever
know Ness right you know so you don't
ever I never expected anything but I'm
just wondering if you saw anything or if
you noticed like that's weird or that
make sense
um I didn't know her I rarely worked
with her she rarely talked to me ask you
to join nexium yes she did yeah is it
next Seymour Nexus nexium Nexus is the
thing you get into the country with yeah
it was that wasn't the name of it when I
just moved to LA and she for someone who
didn't talk to me ever FaceTime me and
said they had a an organization of women
it was a retreat you know it's support
it's because I didn't know any I knew
you you were the only person I knew in
Los Angeles and it sounded strange and
it was also expensive and I didn't have
the money and I didn't end up doing it
and that's what it was and I think there
was a part of me that was like she was
willing she asked me she knew what was
happening although I hear it became that
later but the fact that she was like oh
you're lonely and new come on over so
she felt like she'd felt your
vulnerability yeah and I don't know if
at the time that's what it was that's
what it was it could have genuinely been
let's read books and talk about them and
were you considering it at that point no
I mean cuz you thought maybe was
retreated there's no part in here that
thought maybe this will help me yeah of
course yeah I just couldn't afford to do
it so if you could afford it you
probably would probably would have gone
I think God I was broke yeah right yeah
geez Louise but I I was surprised I was
surprised she's a very smart woman
that's one thing I knew about her she
was very smart
yeah so that's why I don't understand I
don't think anybody will understand
sometimes you see things that will that
happen in the world and you're like why
what this just doesn't add up but when
you let it comes down to it I think how
well do you really know someone I mean
I'm on Smallville for seven years and I
think I got to know Tom when he came in
the podcast the very first time I was
gonna say and that's when we started
just talking about a lot of well because
we always we always laughed all you want
to do in set was laugh but to connect to
really you know and Kristen would come
into town after the small bows over and
we'd have dinner and we start to get to
know each other yeah and you after
Smallville we'd start to get to know
each other in a different you're on a
show it's just sort of like it's not
like it's fake but it's just not it's
not yes but I mean it's the same thing
for me Erica I've become close with in
the past few years Kristen's same thing
Tom and his his fiancee and just you
Jesse you going to the wedding I'm in it
oh I am I'm just showing up are you
really yeah but I didn't get to know
them and we went to Cabo and I got to
know Tom in that environment where he
was just loose and kind and first thing
oh my god the loudest guy he like jumped
two giant doors Tom cut it out where
he's always telling me to come out so
yeah we are we're like brothers yeah you
got yours agreed together well look this
I had a blast first of all I cannot
thank you enough for being so open this
is the most I talked to Ryan too but it
was it was warranted it felt comfortable
and Ryan I think I'd like to talk to you
more great news if other people are
cooled it sure comfortable with that
yeah I mean but it's I mean it's mostly
about the two of you guys I'm just I
know here you know a microphone which is
fun until year later is like um my agent
will call you my lawyer cuz I I want 25%
until my name is on the pod guys
anywhere but it's inside he will my
concern with raising Laura featuring
quiet Ryan
thank you for allowed to be inside of
you
that was her using the CBD uncommon
apothecary and it sounded like a fart
that was perfect rub it all over your
back and all that stuff you guys I'm
sure you've heard me talk about it but
it's it's great stuff and hey what's
your handles Twitter van Deakins 22 and
Instagram super vandi Mandy kins is a
nickname that Patrick Warburton gave me
and that's how that's time yeah
Vande cans I bet he's like this he's
like Laura how are ya
you know Patrick Warburton doesn't he
kind of do that there yeah so uh Mandy
Kenz well he's paddy Warbucks paddy
Warbucks didn't name himself that I
don't know that's what I called him can
you get him on the show actually there's
someone I think I could get on the show
that you who you'd like we'll talk about
a later look this has been great take
your mug
take your CBD we're gonna see each other
at a con soon guys thank you for
listening to the podcast Laura
Vandervoort thank you for allowing me to
be inside of you you're welcome this is
really fun alright guys so what'd you
think of the episode we're gonna have a
thing where you know I want you to tweet
I want you to let me know what you think
and if you have any questions or things
you want me to ask guests in particular
doesn't matter about the guests as much
as you like to surprise you with a guest
and even if you don't know them
obviously you listen anyway and that's
why I love you and that's why I'm still
doing this although I'd still do it cuz
I love doing it but this episode with
Laura was interesting and it's always on
the other podcast I have in love with
Chris Sullivan and Michael Rosenbaum mom
we had my ex-girlfriend on on Andrea
Bogart and it was really interesting she
brought her child and we talked about
why it didn't work and who I was and it
was I was really vulnerable and this
podcast having Laura on we were both
going through our own [ __ ] and she she
acknowledges it you know she talks about
almost dying as a child her parents and
and just working and you know I think
she opens up more so than I think she
would have when we dated which is
telling and I think I'm the same way I
think we're both in on different in
different places I think that's just a
maturity thing maybe not with me but I
think that you know as we grow
and you start to realize that
vulnerability is good and people seeing
emotions that's actually healthy getting
rid of bad habits I think that's a big
thing and so this this podcast was
really nice and you know my grandpa died
Laura text me immediately and she says
if you need anything and I know she
meant it she met herb she loved herb and
I'm glad that we've from doing these
conventions Laura and I have been able
to be friends again and it's not like we
hang out but it's nice to see her and
goof off and just be friends and and I
think that shows a maturity I'm gonna
read some of these messages from the
message board you can go to hello at
inside of you podcast com or you could
tweet me and Instagram me and if so this
is part of the outro for what we're
doing now I just want to read you some
of these questions okay hi Michael this
comes from Liz Anne she's an actor
writer storyteller I've been listening
to your podcast for a while now and I've
I felt compelled to write in after
listening to your interviews with Andie
MacDowell and Jamie King whether you
ever read this random email or not I
just felt like I had to reach out and
tell you how amazing I think the show is
you and your team have created something
quite special inside of you is one of
the most honest podcasts I've ever heard
yes it's therapy for you and your guests
but also for us as listeners Amen
lizanne when you ain't a word Andy we're
talking about her experience with Bill
Murray and the idea that she merely
wanted to please him it really hit a
chord like wanting to please your father
is how I think you put it I'm still at
the beginning of my acting career five
years in a recently worked opposite a
comedic legend to hear the two of you
speak about something that felt similar
to my own experience was quite
comforting sometimes you just want to
know you're doing a good job
Jamie's interview she says when you both
spoke about feeling safe about
meditation about your own personal
journey to connecting to a higher power
and how having a routine helps when it
comes to battling depression it was so
deeply refreshing to hear it was just a
lovely reminder to me that in order to
be of service to others you have to take
care of yourself first you're making a
difference in the world by merely being
honest about every aspect of this life
so thank you thank you
putting everything you've got into this
podcast well thank you for listening and
thank you I'm just I'm blessed I'm
grateful that it helped you in some way
Jonathan hey Rose you just want to let
you know how much I appreciate you in
your podcasts been listening for a
couple months now and it seriously
changed my life being able to hear so
many of these people I find to be very
successful in here how they're going
through or have been through so many of
the same things I'm going through is
amazing to me I have a bipolar mom an
alcoholic dad and to hear you talk to
people that have gone through the same
things and how they dealt with it helps
so much you and Zack Levi just about
brought me to tears talking about your
mother's I related so much to y'all in
that moment I'm currently listening to
Jamie King and her talking about finding
God in a bookstore almost brought me to
tears I paused it and started to write
you this message because I had to let
you know how much this means to me and
I'm sure to so many others that actually
just brought me to almost tears Ryan's
in the room so I won't do it I viewed
most of these people as celebrities and
not much more but you have completely
changed my view on so many of them you
have now made me a fan of them as people
not just for their work ain't that the
truth man that's what that's exactly
what I'm trying to do I appreciate what
you're doing so much I listen to so many
other podcasts and none of it has
grabbed me like yours I've also started
listening to your new podcast with Sully
and currently going through a hard
breakup this has become the perfect time
and I found myself trying harder to be
to better myself
I started going to therapy and it's
thanks to you sorry for such a long
message but I felt you should know how
much you're appreciated thanks so much
PS your podcast is way better than Dax's
I love Dex he won't listen to this
anyway he doesn't have time Tim
lastly hey man I don't know if you're
actually gonna read this but thanks for
doing this podcast and showing me that
people that it may seem to have it all
have gone through hardships and tough
times in their lives
the recent Dane Cook episode hit home
when he spoke about the relationship he
had with his father being basically all
about sports I too had the same type of
relationship with my father in toast
untimely passing in January of this year
unlike Danes father
dad was a Mets fan that's funny so my
dad is and what I am you and I both know
how that 86 World Series turned out
anyway thanks for doing this podcast and
making me feel comfortable in my own
feelings and every now and then bring a
tear to my eye all love Tim it's nice to
read these Ryan that's really nice it is
it's it's nice to just kind of like this
is about being present it's like that's
why I wanted to start doing these outros
of reading things that people say and
absorbing them and saying hey I'm
listening to you you know it makes me
feel good that it that we're doing
something right here you know really
thoughtful yeah it was you know so guys
have a happy happy holiday if you're
bored you know listen to left on Laurel
our CD still out it's been out for about
a month now thank you for everybody came
out to the autograph signing in Covina
chaos records thank you for everybody
came out to the Roxy who listened to the
stage at online performance from us
thank you for buying merch for listening
to the band thank you for listening to
the podcast and love podcast inside of
your podcast
thank you for your endless support happy
holidays
happy new year thank you for allowing me
to be inside all of you
[Music]
you